so as described i'll be describing um
our approach to cellular phagocytosis
applications
and in particular focusing on the
characterization of anti-cd47 antibodies
as potential novel novel immunotherapies
so the webinar will take the following
structure
to start with i'd like to describe
the promise of cancer immunotherapy but
not just talk about t
cells actually look beyond that at
other cell types immune cell types and
then i would like to talk about
real-time
life cell phagocytosis assays both in
general terms
but also specifically around the
principle and validation
and then having uh demonstrated
validated assays
show how they can be used to
characterize anti-cd47 mediated
phagocytosis
of human leukemia t cells
and then thinking about how
complementary
phenotypic assays can be used um in
alignment
with phagocytosis assays really show how
we can gain an
additional mechanistic mechanistic
insight
and then try to wrap things up by
describing
a summary and perspectives as already
has been described there will be a q a
session at the end of this
webinar and i'd like to introduce both
jillian lovell
and nicola bevan two of the scientists
who are instrumental in development
of this application who will assess
assist me
during that questions and answer session
as has also been highlighted please use
the
live cell answers at select science uh
to submit your questions
so i think most people are aware that
the um
the promise of cancer immunotherapy is
huge
and a lot of this is focused on the
modulation of
t cells either through the engineering
of the t
cells such as car t therapies or through
the blockade of checkpoints which
prevent the inhibition of t cell killing
function
and there's been some really nice recent
clinical successes
which has really bolstered the
enthusiasm for this area of science
however it is should be noted
that there is a lot more beyond
just t cells there are many other immune
cell types
and in immune cell functions that want
to be targeted
and most notably here we can think about
macrophages
and that particularly their function
their role in
tumor cell clearance is really taking a
lot of interest at the moment
and a lot of that interest is actually
being uh driven
by er of weissman at the
stanford university in california
and this quotation really
really nicely exemplifies some of the
challenge
faced when thinking about this is a
novel therapy
i'll read it out to you macrophage media
cytotoxicity occurs primarily via
phagocytosis
which is technically challenging to
assay and requires microscopic
visualization or flow cytometry
to quantify cellular engulfment for
these reasons macrophages
are underappreciated as effector cells
that can target cancer
and this really sets us a nice backdrop
to say
how we feel that real time light cell
analysis
can really aid researchers in this field
and really enable
i think novel therapies within uh
immunotherapy
before going into the specifics of the
phagocytosis application
i wanted to really talk about some of
the general key features of live cell
analysis systems
and here we've just got six of those
exemplified
firstly we've got automated real-time
analysis
it's really key to be able to do simple
hands-free
analysis such that you can gain the full
kinetic response of the biology that
you're interested in studying
and by doing this in such a simple way
you can get
avoid the need for complex sample
preparation for readouts
and importantly not have to pre-define
endpoints when you actually want to take
your measurements
by using image-based methodologies
and you're really able to understand the
spatial relationship
between different cell types key when
you're looking at
co-culture models and once you've been
able to
make measurements you can go back and
provide qualitative
validation of those measurements
to gain additional confidence
flexibility is always key
both in terms of optics readouts
the plastic wear and importantly the
cell types that you can use
we want the researchers to be able to
use whatever cells they feel
are most appropriate for their
application
being able to multiplex multiple
readouts within the same well
allows you to ensure that every data
point is
as information rich as possible
one of the nice things around live cell
analysis
is it not only has its place within
assays it actually um fits to the entire
continuum
of the live cell assays portfolio
whether that's
cell culture cell manipulation as well
as assays
and importantly at the end of the such
an approach the cells are not exhausted
they're still free to be used
in more traditional endpoint
measurements
when considering the use of live cells
it's always
critical that they're not perturbed
because you if your
assay methodology perturbs them it's
liable to interfere with the readout
to achieve this you need exquisite
environmental control
particularly crucial when looking at
longer term assays
our approach and philosophy is if you
can put your methodology
inside a standard cell culture incubator
where you have excellent control of
temperature carbon dioxide and
humidity this really gives you the
maximum chance of being non-perturbing
and then finally thinking about
non-perturbance
we want capacity and throughput without
affecting the biology
and if you can do this by running
different experiments in parallel
both for multiple vessels and multiple
users this really maximizes
the capability of such an approach
and finally being able to actually bring
together
all of these features of live cell
analysis with both non-perturbing
reagents
and fully validated lifestyle protocols
really maximizes the ability to have a
fully integrated approach
so specifically thinking about the
phagocytosis application
firstly i'd like to describe the
application principle
we have developed our own reagent the
inky site frodo
red sable red labeling kit
whereby we can label target cells
with a ph sensitive probe which when
those cells are in
standard media outside of the phagocyte
they have little or no fluorescence
but once they become engulfed by the
phagocyte
they enter the phagosome and ultimately
the favored lysosome
which has a much lower ph and we can
exploit that low ph
by using this ph sensitive probe which
will
increase dramatically its fluorescence
when in that environment
and if you can see the video the movie
running on the right hand side
you can see the larger elongated
macrophage
engulfing these smaller target cells
and once they've become engulfed there's
an increase in red fluorescence within
that macrophage and that is
fundamentally what we want to measure
in terms of how we go about conducting
such an assay
we've got the protocol and workflow
shown here which requires a few simple
steps
step one you have to seed your effect to
cell
which is your phagocyte and in most
cases will be a macrophage
once they've had the opportunity to
adhere to the plastic which is usually
overnight
you can go ahead and label your target
cells this is achieved
by creating a cell suspension
which in turn is then the photo label is
added
incubated for approximately hour the
cells are then washed
during that incubation period at step
three we can
treat our effector cells if that's what
we would wish to do
and then at step four we create the co
culture where those labeled target cells
are added to the effector cells and then
the
plate can be added to the live cell
imaging platform
for full analysis
by lowering
all of these features the reagent
the real-time analysis software and the
hardware imaging platform
you can again really get to see the
fully integrated solution
prior to actually demonstrating
validation
of the application i wanted to highlight
the step first is to actually validate
the labeling of your target cells
and to achieve this the target cells
upon labeling
rather than being added to your effector
cells
can be just added to a low ph buffer
such as a citrate
ph4 buffer by adding them to this low ph
buffer
the cells will spontaneously fluoresce
and they can be added to the inky site
platform
whereby on the left you can see you can
measure fluorescence intensity
and as you would predict as you put more
frodo label in
you get an increase in fluorescence and
on the
uh on the right you can see the object
count which is a surrogate for cell
count
and unlike the fluorescence intensity
yes we see a moderate increase
in the object count quite soon
you realize that you've labeled the
cells
sufficiently that all of them have been
counted
and in this particular example we would
take 250 nanogram per ml
to be an optimal concentration to count
sufficiently the number of labeled cells
and this approach has been used to
validate a range of different cell types
and these are listed on the right hand
side it should be noted that this type
of validation needs to be
conducted each time you try a new target
cell
once you've actually labeled those
target cells we can actually then start
thinking about how we
use these within a phagocytosis assay
and here we've got some images of some
j774a
mouse immortalized macrophages as the
effector cell
and the target cell is um apoptotic year
cats
these are apoptotic such that they
externalize phosphatidylserine
and induce phagocytosis without the need
for any
additional stimuli and the top three
panels
we have the phase contrast image
overlaid with the fluorescence image
the bottom three panels are the
corresponding
phase image with the segmentation mask
and what you can see in these images is
that
at t equals zero little or no
fluorescence is observed
and no therefore no corresponding mask
but at
the t equals 12 hours and even more so
at t equals 24 hours
we see an increase in fluorescence and
it's
important to note that the segmentation
mask corresponds very nicely
in addition you can see not only
the increase in fluorescence you can
also see a qualitative effect
of cell clearing gaps
appearing between the cells within the
co culture
providing additional confidence that
phagocytosis
is occurring
being able to use time-lapse imagery
we can monitor this um phenomena over
the entire time
course of the phagocytosis
on the left-hand side we can here we can
see the time
course of the increase in red
fluorescence area
plotted against time and where you have
apoptotic target cells
where there's been a strong signal for
phagocytosis
you see a large time dependent increase
in fluorescent area
in contrast the non-apoptotic label
target cells where there's a
little or no no stimulus for
phagocytosis
little or no fluorescent increases
observed
and this approach has been taken with a
range of different target cells
and a range of different effector cells
and it's a very robust system
which we feel you can use many many
different cell types
because we can use microtiter plates
this approach
is very amenable to conducting
pharmacological
evaluation and here we've got four
different
inhibitors of
phagocytosis and again we're looking at
the phagocytosis
of apoptosiocats
and we have the highest concentration in
row a
and the lowest concentration in row g
and controls in row h and you can see
um even just looking at the 96 well
plate view
a concentration dependent effect that is
more strongly shown on the right hand
side where we've just taken cytokines in
d
showing that the mean time course from
the we
three replicates and from that we can
derive
the concentration response curve which
enables the determination of an ic50 of
230 nanomolar
so hopefully what i've convinced you so
far is this is a robust
assay of phagocytosis but we want to
demonstrate how this can be used
to really evaluate anti-cd47
mediated cell phagocytosis and for those
of you who are
um unfamiliar with this particular area
cd47 has been identified as a
an exciting new target within the
immunotherapy field
it is expressed highly on the outside
of tumor cells and when it interacts
with the surf alpha
ligand expressed on the surface of
macrophages
it creates almost an invisibility cloak
which causes
a allowed don't eat me signal to be
transmitted such that it protects the
tumor
from macrophage eating
a addition of something like an
anti-cd47 antibody
which prevents the interaction between
cd47
and serp alpha prevents this uh cloaking
and therefore it really means that those
macrophages
can start interacting and potentially
engulfing and clearing tumors
initially excitement was based around
various different types of leukemia
but more recently as exemplified in the
paper shown here on the right
there has been even good progress made
with solid tumors
such as small cell lung cancers and this
whole approach now
is even moved into the clinic with the
47 inc
commissioning the camellia clinical
study
which is in the early stages but there's
great excitement
so the question is with our approach can
we
observe cd47 mediated cell phagocytosis
and the simple answer is yes here we're
using
bone marrow derived macrophages which
are primary
macrophages as the effector cell and the
target cell
is ccrf cemt lymphoblasts
and these were selected due to their
high expression of cd47
inclusion of an anti-cd47 antibody
causes concentration dependent increases
in phagocytosis in contrast to the igg
control
by determining the area under the curve
analysis
on the left hand side we can really
strongly exemplify this concentration
dependence
as previously described we can always
validate and
gain confidence that what we're
observing with those quantifications
is borne out with our images here we've
got
the phase contrast and
fluorescence blended images on the top
panels
and you can see the increase in
fluorescence and the evidence
for clearing and on the bottom three
panels
across the time course we can see just
the fluorescence in
images showing that increase in
fluorescence so this really gives us
confidence that we are really measuring
anti-cd47 mediated cell phagocytosis
what's also interesting is if we take
those same
target cells and we investigate the
phagocytosis using different effector
cells
we see very different temporal profiles
here we've taken the assay out to 12
hours although the previous data was
only shown up to four hours
and what you can see is in the dark blue
you can see that using bone marrow
derived macrophages
it's quite a transient signal in
contrast using mouse macrophages j774
cells that's that's a much more
sustained
signal at the present time this is
fairly preliminary data
it's unclear what the mechanism is
behind this
but it does really emphasize how being
able to measure the entire time course
is really important
having observed this cd47 mediated
cell phagocytosis it does beg the
question
whether the cd47 antibody is having any
direct effect
on the target cells and here we're just
looking
at the monoculture of the ccos cem
target cells
and by measuring just the phase contrast
area
which allows us to determine percentage
confluence we can understand whether or
not we're having any effect on
proliferation
and what you can see under control
conditions or in the presence of the igg
control
you get nice proliferation of your
target cells
if you include camtasia which induces
apoptosis
you get almost complete inhibition of
proliferation
the anti-cd47 antibody
does appear to cause moderate reduction
in proliferation but interestingly that
effect
only occurs at the later time points as
evidenced by the bar graphs
first at three hours where you see
minimal effect whereas a notable effect
of 24 hours
although these these effects at 24 hours
are outside of the effects that we've
observed phagocytosis
again it begs and second question which
is
is apoptosis being induced by cd47 or
anti-seizure 47 antibody
and so here on the left hand side bar
graph what we have
is the phagocytosis out from the co
culture of cco mceff cem
target cells with j7748.1 mouse
macrophages
or following apoptosis induction with
camtasia you can see a really striking
fatal phagocytosis induction
by contrast though if we look in
monoculture of the
rf cells and look at whether or not
apoptosis is being induced either using
an annexin 5 readout
which looks at ps externalization or a
caspase-37 readout
which looks at the activation of the
caspase
enzyme we can see that there is little
or no activity
of the anti-cd47 antibody by contrast to
the camtasia which we know
will induce apoptosis this is
really strong evidence that that
anti-cd47
induced phagocytosis is not acting
through an apoptosis induction
so to try to wrap everything up into a
simple summary
hopefully i've demonstrated that
real-time lifestyle analysis
coupled with a novel reagent
enables direct cell measurements
of phagocytosis and adds true
valuable biological insight and enhanced
productivity
which is in contrast with some of the
common cell-based assay methods
where fixing and or lifting is required
and there's really a lack of temporal
resolution or verification by
visualization and importantly
this approach is very amenable
to the characterization of anti-cd47
antibodies
which promote phagocytosis and really
certainly commensurate with the descr
modulators and potentially other
modulators of phagocytosis by
macrophages
and this whole approach can be
complemented
by using other real-time
applications such as proliferation and
apoptosis
to either confirm or deny other
mechanisms